you look for cold fusion TV why flower
bees
hi welcome to another cold fusion video
so it's finally happening
Tesla has started production of the
model 3 and it's two weeks earlier than
planned
the Tesla Model 3 will be one of the
world's first high-performance long
range of medium priced all-electric car
from the masses established car
manufacturers may have fully electric
cars but they're either too expensive or
lack the full focus of the parent
company this usually results in
strange-looking cars or glorified golf
carts
this puts Tesla and the model 3 at an
advantage but how long will this last on
the other hand newcomers that are dubbed
Tesla killers like Faraday future and
lucid motors may have good looking
futuristic cars the brand recognition
and loyalty just isn't there yet and in
addition there's some uncertainty of
real-world performance as these vehicles
iron in mass production yet
in short Tesla has a head start with the
model 3 this is the make-or-break moment
for Tesla a critical test to see if they
can put all of what they've learned in
the past nine years or so into a
mass-market product if they succeed it
would put the company in a better
financial situation and solidify them as
a leader in electric vehicles does they
fail it will be catastrophic for the
company in this video we'll take a look
at what's happening the first deliveries
of the model 3 will take place on July
28th Elon Musk stated that production
would ramp up quickly
and there will be 20,000 model freeze
produced a month starting in December he
expects to push half a million cars a
year by 2018
despite this delivery wait times are
going to be very long according to musk
he warned that buyers who want to car
before 2019 need to make their
reservations as soon as possible looking
at the broader scope of things research
analyst jean master likens the model 3
to an iPhone moment not only for
electric cars but also for autonomous
driving that's behind your analogy
between the model 3 and the iPhone well
iPhone to really set the stone the stage
for what smartphones could ultimately be
I think the mile tree has that same
opportunity not just for electric
vehicles but also for the opportunity
on autonomy this is going to be a
radical change similar to the iPhone
there was a radical change where we went
from a flip phone to a computer in your
pocket so let's take a quick look at the
specs the most basic configuration of
the model 3 will get you 250 miles of
range but variants with bigger batteries
could go over 300 miles in a single
charge
for comparison a four-cylinder Toyota
Camry one of the world's most popular
cars will give you an average of just
under 500 miles per tank the slowest
Model 3 can accelerate from 0 to 100
kilometers an hour or 0 to 60 miles an
hour in 5.6 seconds
rumours suggests to the ludicrous mode
of the Model 3 would be able to do this
under 3 seconds a 2017 four-cylinder
Camry we'll do this in eight point five
seconds four-wheel drive options will
also be available for the model three
and Tesla's autopilot package of
electronic driving aids such as
automatic lane changing road sign
reading and collision detection will be
available the base model starts for
thirty five thousand US dollars with
incentives but there's no price given
for the top model just yet until now the
company has been positioning itself as a
luxury car manufacturer producing cars
and relatively small numbers and
typically selling them for $120,000 or
more from a business point of view
Tesla needed to do this as the
technology that they were putting
together was done in such a way that was
new and expensive now that we've lured
the robes and have honed their craft
they can increase production volume and
move down market into the general auto
space must also said that Tesla is
working to automate its assembly plant
even further to increase the Model 3
output at a shareholders meeting he
disclosed that the company was looking
at additional plans in addition to the
one that they have in Fremont California
the solution possibly China Tesla has
had discussions with Chinese officials
about opening a plant near Shanghai this
makes sense as China accounted for 15%
of Tesla's revenue in 2016
to prepare for the arrival of the model
3 Tesla built an 8 billion dollar
factory in Nevada to produce batteries
for the electric cars this year Tesla
also raised 1 billion dollars through
offerings of stock and debt
interestingly a Chinese Internet giant
Tencent Holdings acquired a 5% stake in
the company the company needs this extra
capital because he continues to make
losses each quarter in the first quarter
Tesla lost 397 million almost a hundred
million more than last year but its
revenue has more than doubled
year-over-year to 2.7 billion so it all
comes back to the model 3 the model 3 is
the only real opportunity to turn this
trend around the clock is ticking and
investors are getting nervous
although stock markets are a complete
speculation nowadays the company lost 12
billion dollars in market share just in
the last week and 63 billion since its
June 23rd peak at which they were the
most valuable car company in the u.s. of
course Tesla does a lot more things than
cars but this still shows the sentiment
this drop and Tesla stock price comes
hot off the heels from Volvo saying that
they're going to start phasing out
petrol cars and eventually move to
all-electric cars the competition is
just around the corner and the stakes
couldn't be higher
again if Tesla succeeds it will be the
start of a Brady era for the company but
if there's a recall or some other
failure it could spell disaster
regardless this is a very interesting
time in history right now and I'm
certainly watching to see what happens
in any situation the consumer winds and
whether you love them or hate them you
must take your hat off to Tesla for
getting this ball rolling an electric
cars I hope you liked that quick roundup
about the Tesla Model 3 and what it
means for Tesla but on another topic I
know a few of you are going to be asking
about my Bitcoin and blockchain videos
so I'm going to update you about that so
I've heared some delays as my original
blockchain expert can no longer do a
video in a timely fashion so I've had to
connect with some other experts but in
short I'm still working at it so that's
very stuff of the screen just yet the
videos are coming
anyway thanks for watching this video if
you kneel feel free to subscribe give
this video a thumbs up if you liked it
this has been to gogo helping watching
ColdFusion and I'll see you again soon
for another video
cheers guys everyone thinking
[Music]